this is a mouse lemur it's the smallest
primate on earth the most abundant other
than humans and it's adorable but could
it also be an important animal for the
study of genetics even rivaling the
common lab mouse mouse lemurs are found
all over Madagascar like mice mouse
lemurs are small have short generation
times and bear relatively large numbers
of offspring which is useful for a
search but as primates they have an
added bonus of being much more closely
related to humans biochemist mark krosno
from Stanford University believes this
is a winning combination he says that
mouse lemurs lab friendly
characteristics combined with their
relatedness to humans could allow
scientists to use them to ask questions
about health behavior and genetics which
simply couldn't be done with other
animals but there's a catch classic
genetic techniques like gene knockouts
are difficult to do in primates owing to
strict ethical guidelines so krosno
needed a different approach his work is
based here in ranima fauna National Park
Madagascar wild mouse lemurs have been
captured and released here for
ecological studies for years
mark wondered could he use the same
techniques to start building a genetic
database of wild mouse lemurs with
enough data he could search for natural
genetic variations associated with
physical characteristics like disease
instead of creating mutations to study
genetics he would just look for them in
a wild population for an approach like
this to work krasnoye needed lots of
data and that takes a lot of time and
effort so he came up with a plan he
enlisted local Malagasy people to help
under the watchful eye of his team
Malagasy graduate students were taught
how to capture mouse lemurs using traps
baited with banana
he's also extending this training to
high school students in the hopes that
one
day thousands of lemurs could be
captured and documented by local people
in their own backyard after being
captured the lemurs go through a sort of
boot camp where scientists measure
everything from their strength to their
gait then they take tiny tissue and
blood samples for genetic sequencing
microchip the lemurs for identification
and release them back onto the exact
branch where they were captured crass no
and his team say they've already found a
whole host of naturally occurring
mutations linked to diabetes progressive
eye disease obesity and all without any
invasive testing by combining ecological
field techniques with advanced
sequencing and citizen science Marc
hopes to build the mouse lemur into a
leading model organism a living genetic
library running wild in the forests of
Madagascar but there's still a long way
to go existing models including primate
models like macaques and baboons aren't
going anywhere soon so much is already
known about them in lab studies and some
researchers have pointed out that if you
want to study natural genetic variation
then why not just use humans the krosno
is still confident and time will tell if
these adorable little critters will help
bring his vision to life
you
[Music]